the Democrats move forward with the
house impeachment vote president Trump
sends what letter to Nancy Pelosi and
Mitch McConnell plots his next steps I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today and express it VPN calm / Manuel
do you feel uncertain about things these
days does it feel like the country is
existing on knife's edge does it feel as
though the economy could be inflated or
could it possibly be depressed do you
know anything I don't know anything it
feels like nobody knows anything because
everything is a mess and it's about this
time you should be thinking maybe I
should diversify my portfolio because if
you don't know what's coming and nobody
does it is a good idea to have one foot
in each area of the market which means
you have only 12 feet but one of those
feet should actually be in precious
metals and this is where Birch gold
comes in I trust the folks at Birch gold
I've known them for years they've been
working with me for years right now they
actually have a really great offer for
the holidays they call it the silver
stocking stuffer event when you contact
Birch gold group this month to buy
precious metals once you complete your
purchase before December 20th Birch gold
will send you free silver it's a great
stocking stuffer or Hanukkah gift you
have a conversation with the Birch gold
expert have all your questions answered
ask all them so you feel like you have
full information and then at that point
you might want to think about putting at
least some of your money and precious
metals that the government cannot
inflate that the government cannot mess
around with you know an actual hard
asset that has a price go check out
Birch gold right now all you have to do
is text Ben - 47 47 47 and claim your
eligibility for their special offer
today again text Ben - 47 47 47 we're
always grateful to work with Birch gold
and I think you'll enjoy working with
them to text Ben to 47 47 47 all right
so today is the day today is the big
historic oh so everybody's very up for
this impeachment thing very exciting
it's a historic day so much history
making history history history hey let
me just explain something
history will care I don't and the reason
is cuz it's like going to a movie where
you already know the ending it's the
most predictable movie in the world the
Democrats are going to impeach the
Republicans are going to acquit in the
Senate it's not going to have any masks
impact on the election everything in the
world is baked into this cake old shoes
human feces everything is in the cake
when it comes to 2020 the only met the
only factor that is not baked into the
cake is who the Democrats will nominate
we'll get to that a little bit later on
in the show when it comes to trump
everything is baked into the cake and I
realized this morning I was thinking
about this with regard to how people
view President Trump because really how
you view the impeachment is a referendum
on how you view President Trump and even
more than president Trump how you feel
about the broader political situation in
the United States I don't think that
many people are actually looking at the
charges in this case
and reading the Democrats a six hundred
and fifty nine page report and then
reading the Republicans 200 page
response and being like well after
considering all of the transcripts and
all of the facts here's where I come
down on the legal mettle of this case on
the evidentiary burden hasn't been met
or has it not been met I don't think
that most Americans are thinking that
way I think most Americans are thinking
to themselves is this impeachment
appropriate or is this impeachment not
are the people trying to impeach Trump
politically motivated or are they
motivated by just concern for the
Constitution and preventing foreign
countries from interfering in America's
elections I feel like we've been
speaking past each other for quite a
while here and so there are a couple
issues on which this is a referendum on
Trump and then there are a couple issues
where this is a referendum on American
politics as a whole and it's all wrapped
up together in a ball and that's what
people's opinions on impeachment are
when it comes down to this I think do
you think that President Trump is a
murderer or a CEO coroner is he a
political murderer or is he a political
coroner so if you are on the Left you
look at President Trump and you say look
at this wild dude look at this person
he lies frequently he says things that
are dishonest he he breaks every rule of
the presidency he says things out loud
that should never be said he gets on
phone calls and just jabbers to the
president of Ukraine about his political
opponents he's the kind of guy who will
say or do anything he'll insult people
on Twitter he rips the media and then he
degrades the view of people of the media
because he sees them as his enemy he
calls them the enemy of the people this
is somebody who cannot be normalized and
this is why you've heard Democrats say
and people in the media say since
literally the day he was alive didn't
really sense that he was nominated we
cannot accept this as the new normal
cannot accept this as the new normal in
other words Trump murdered all of these
conventions right there were all of
these conventions that the media were
trustworthy and Trump murdered it he
took it out back without it with a
pickaxe and buried it in the I like like
Leon Trotsky that Trump has murdered
civility before this we were a republic
of comedy and you see this in the
rewriting of Barack Obama's history by
the media it has now been an accepted
part of the media's history the Barack
Obama was actually a politician of
comedy and unity and spends his days
trying to cut bipartisan deals which for
any of us who have a memory longer than
that of the fish Dory in Finding Nemo we
have recognized that's a bunch of crap
okay but for folks on the Left it's like
well you know Barack Obama that was a
man of honor and civility civility and I
remember a lot of civility from broccoli
but they do they do don't you remember
those days when there was a consensus
that politics stopped it water's edge
that you never militarized foreign
policy on behalf of your own political
viewpoint and now Donald Trump has rats
that he's the murderer of that political
consensus the idea that we were all in
it together and it's true domestically
to Trump is polarized us along domestic
political lines whereas once we were
unified it is Trump who has who has
wrecked everything and is the view of
the left and the view of the media when
it comes to impeachment they say well if
we don't impeach now then we've broken
impeachment forever if we don't impeach
now then the very conventions of
impeachment will have been destroyed for
all time Trump will have murdered them
it will just be another casualty of his
evil his the view of the left is that
Donald Trump is the political murderer
right that he is Michael Myers and that
he is stalking Jamie Lee Curtis and that
Jamie Lee Curtis is all that is good and
right with the American Republic and
then there is the view of the people who
are I would say probably on the middle
or on the right and that view is that
Trump is not actually a political
murderer yes he exacerbates a lot of the
problems that the country has already
been experiencing no he's not militating
against any of those but Trump is much
more a coroner than he is a murderer
that his election represents the
recognition by the American people that
all these things were already dead Trump
came upon the the still-warm corpse of
American politics and then he declared
it dead and so Democrats seeing a man
standing over the body are going oh that
guy probably killed him right that guy's
the murderer
and Republicans conservatives
independence they're looking at trumpet
they're going nope that body was dead
and Trump didn't exactly like get down
on his hands and knees and perform CPR
on the guy but he ain't the murderer
he's the coroner he's the person who
came along and declared all of these
things dead so the media the media's
credibility was gone it was already gone
Newt Gingrich was hacking it in 2012 to
wild acclaim the media had already made
clear that they were nothing but but
sort of drool carriers for Barack Obama
so Donald Trump coming along and ripping
the media that was nothing new that was
just him declaring something dead that
we all knew was dead and when it comes
to civility Barack Obama was going
around insulting everybody who didn't
agree with him it's a bitter clinger joe
biden was going around saying that Mitt
Romney Mitt Romney was gonna put black
people back in Chains and he was an evil
person who put dogs on top of his car in
all of this he was it was interest
groups in favor of Barack Obama super
PACs running ads suggesting that Mitt
Romney had fired people so their wives
would get cancer and die so don't tell
me the civility died because Donald's
from put a stake through its heart
Donald Trump is the coroner he came
along he said let their civility it's
dead so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
pretend it to that don't sound be
civility here the same thing when it
comes to this quorum quote consensus
there was no consensus on American
foreign policy politics did not stop at
water's edge
most of us are old enough to remember
when mainstream members of the left were
suggesting that George W Bush was a war
criminal and should be tried in The
Hague we remember when the Democrats
were undermining the the Iraq war when
we remember when the Democrats were
pulling precipitously out of Iraq and
leaving room for Isis so let's not
pretend that there was some sort of
broad foreign policy consensus when
Barack Obama Ben Rhodes were lying to
the faces of the American people about
the supposed moderation of the regime in
Iran you remember all of that and so
Donald Trump came along and again acted
as the coroner and he looks at time of
death 11:20 and he's just the coroner he
ain't the murderer and then finally when
it comes to impeachment and that's
today's news people have no left they're
like well if we don't impeach over this
and we won't be able to impeach over
anything and you know what there there
is truth to the notion that whenever
Congress slides
it's impeachable responsibilities that
the the ability to impeach is degraded
there's no question that that is true
that the less you use a particular
impeachment is like any other muscle of
the political body politic unless you
use it the MOR atrophies it's only been
used four times in American history one
of those times had ended in the
resignation of President Nixon somebody
said to me today somebody on the right
said to me today who's a fan of the
impeachment effort said to me well you
know if President Nixon were around
today he wouldn't be impeached right he
would stick around and the answer is
that's probably true if President Nixon
were in office today
if Watergate had happened it's probably
true that he would have stuck around it
is also true that he was impeached for
actual crimes this impeachment effort to
distinguish it and to be completely fair
this impeachment effort has no crimes
attached to it which is why the
Democrats did not charge bribery that's
why they did not charge wire fraud it is
why they did not charge an obstruction
of justice
instead they crafted these political
crimes to avoid having to prove the
elements of an actual crime so it's
pretty obvious what they're trying to do
here but if you want to say that bad
activity by the President of the United
States is impeachable well guess what
even their President Trump is acting as
a coroner he is not acting as the
murderer so he's not making the problem
any better can't reviving the the honor
and coherence of the presidency but I'm
old enough to remember when Barack
Obama's IRS was targeting conservatives
was finding keywords in IRS applications
and then mixing those IRS applications
for nonprofit status if those nonprofits
happen to be conservative I remember
when that happened and the Republicans
didn't impeach him over it the fact is
impeachment was atrophied the moment the
Bill Clinton was not thrown out of the
thrown out of the White House the man
obviously committed perjury and
obstruction of justice he was not ousted
at that point the political body politic
it was atrophied and so for Democrats to
come around now and be like well this is
completely partisan yeah and it was
completely partisan in 1998 when the
Democrats decided that despite open
crimes by the President of the United
States he's not gonna be impeachable so
Trump declared this thing dead now on a
broad level on a broad level should the
president be impeached on a broad level
most presidents should probably have
been hitched or at least many presidents
should have been impeached when Barack
Obama was launching wars in Libya
without the express permission of
Congress when dot when Barack Obama was
droning American citizens overseas
I mean like what and if you're on the
left when George W Bush was exceeding
his mandate with the war in Iraq using
the authorization to use military force
for Afghanistan and Iraq right all of
these things in any sort of vacuum would
appear as quote unquote impeachable
offenses but in fact is this the
impeachment has been a dead letter for a
long time
civility has been a dead letter for a
long time consensus has been a dead
letter for a long time the media's
credibility have been a debt has been a
dead-letter for a long time and so this
is why I think that Democrats look at
Trump and they see every outrage is a
new outrage a fresh outrage because they
believe that none of this is true they
believe that everything was hunky-dory
under Barack Obama that everything was
wonderful and civil and delightful and
cheerful and happy they pretend the Bush
years didn't exist that Bush was just
one of those wild outliers it's weird
how in the Democratic view every
Republican is an outlier but the fact is
that Donald Trump was the new normal
before Donald Trump was the new normal
Donald Trump was the coroner of POD of
America's politics he was not in fact
the murderer of America's politics now
that does raise the question as to how
we rebuild in American politics in this
arena with all of our institutions
mistrusted and as I say I don't think
that Donald Trump is rebuilding those
institutions I don't think the president
Trump is restoring the integrity of the
White House of the media I don't think
that he's restoring civility I don't
think he's restoring consensus
I'd only he's doing a lot of those
things but that does not mean that
Donald Trump is the person who broke
them he came upon the warm but dead body
of American politics and and here's the
proof of this the Democrats are about to
nominate Bernie Sanders can you imagine
an election between Donald Trump and
Bernie Sanders I mean last time around
if you didn't think that was the death
of American politics Donald Trump versus
Hillary Clinton one of the most widely
despised hated politicians of the last
thirty years against a man who arrived
on the political scene five seconds ago
and had the lowest approval ratings for
any candidate in American history I
don't not to tell you our politics is
broken before Trump Trump was just the
person who made it obvious that the
politics were broken
that's not impeachable you don't put
that up for an election in November you
can do that but the real reason
Democrats want to impeach Trump is
because they want to assume that if it
were not for Trump the American body
politic could be alive and well and that
ain't the case that simply is not the
case okay so
today the impeachment vote is happening
the Democrats are going to impeach
President Trump the media will declare
this a historic moment and then this
thing will move on to the Senate it's
not gonna pay off for the Democrats
politically speaking it's gonna be
pretty ugly for the Democrats actually
politically speaking Jim McGovern
Democrat of Massachusetts chairman of
the House Rules Committee
he says if a president's undermining our
national security and using the federal
government for his own selfish personal
gain is not impeachable concepts then
madam conduct than madam Speaker I don't
know what is again the Democrats
speaking the language of if we don't
impeach an impeachment itself has been
broken
guys impeach was broken quite a while
ago now if you want to ask about whether
you think this particular set of facts
is impeachable my answer for a long time
has been no because I don't think that
you've actually fulfilled I don't think
that you have actually fulfilled the
standard here I don't think that you
have actually fulfilled the criminal
standard necessary to drive bipartisan
approval but with that said again
impeachments been broken for a very long
time to say that this is what breaks the
mold there's never gonna be a legit
impeachment again in American history
barring some sort of resurgent American
unity which I don't see happening in the
near future to you and we'll get to more
of this in just one second first let us
talk about a great holiday gift that
will stand the test of time I'm talking
of course about pearls you are talking
about getting something great for your
wife your girlfriend mom sister let me
tell you the best gift they will women
love jewelry and they love pearls how do
I know and they love pearls from the
pearl source I know this because I've
gotten some before my wife
they are spectacularly beautiful she
loves them and got her a pearl necklace
I also got her a pair of earrings sort
of diamonds stripping down into a Pearl
Earring just gorgeous gorgeous stuff
beautiful beautiful things you can get
them from the pearl source and when you
do you're saving a ton of money you save
70% off retail prices why because the
Pearl source cuts out the middleman
you're shopping online they eliminate
that traditional five-times markup by
jewelry stores they're selling directly
to you the consumer now Christmas and
Hanukkah are already next week good news
it is not too late the pearl source
offers free two-day shipping on every
order everything comes beautifully
packaged in an elegant jewelry box so
it's ready to be given as gift you will
receive your beautiful pearls in time
for the holidays do it now
so that you don't get stuck doing it
later no worries the Pearl source comes
with the no hassle 60-day money-back
guarantee so it's risk-free
so if you get her peace
she doesn't love you can just get the
money back plus with more than 20 years
in the pearl business over 5,000
five-star reviews you can be sure you're
shopping from a trusted retailer by the
way you don't have to trust them and
trust me I know the people who run the
Pearl source I've known them for decades
they are absolutely trustworthy
honorable people they're great
it's a terrific business go check them
out right now the Pearl source calm
slash men enter promo code Bannon
checkout you get an extra twenty percent
off your entire order for everyone on
that Christmas list wife mom sister
daughter it's a gift that lasts the test
of time go straight to the source the
Pearl source the pearl source comb slash
been enter promo code been at checkout
go check it out right now it's basically
last chance before the holidays and you
can still get that shipping in like
they're gonna ship it to you real fast
so you get it before the holidays okay
so the Democrat narrative is that if we
don't impeach over this impeachment is
broken the Republican narrative is
you're cherry-picking the evidence Tom
Cole of Oklahoma the ranking Republican
on the House Rules Committee said the
Democrats were being partisan and using
cherry-picked evidence to fit their
narrative he says if we're really being
honest Democrats have been searching to
impeach Trump since the day he was
elected and that of course is true
they've been they've been looking to
impeach Trump because they believe that
Trump is the aberration the American
body politic was healthy and Trump
murdered it and if we can withdraw Trump
and withdraw the knife everything goes
back to normal except there wasn't a
normal there wasn't than normal in the
first place and I think most Americans
understand this which is why the
impeachment stuff is not going anywhere
people feel like Democrats are partisan
people feel like this has nothing to do
with healing the body politic and
everything to do with exacerbating the
divides inside the body politic this is
how the American people feel so the way
you can tell this most most easily is
the fact that Democrats are not even
running ads on impeachment Republicans
are Nick Korres sanity writing for the
New York Times for the past two months
television ads across central Virginia
have sounded a lot like president from
sweater a rigged process a sham
impeachment no quid pro quo but Pelosi's
witch-hunt continues and ad from the
Republican nonprofit group America first
policies cried as images of Abigail
Spann Berger who represents the region
in Congress flickered on screen span
burger of course is a blue Democrat in a
in a red district or purple district
during the roughly two months the
impeachment inquiry has been underway
Trump and his Republican allies have
flooded the airwaves spending more than
sixteen point seven million dollars on
ads critical of the impeachment effort a
vast majority of those ads attack House
Democrats rather than defending the
president according to advertising
analytics an ad tracking firm
groups are not fighting back directly
are choosing to instead focus mainly on
other issues like health care which
shows you what they think right if they
thought that a referendum on Trump would
win them reelection if they think
they're just shouting that Trump is
gonna skew the election unless you get
out and vote is going to win the
election for them even they don't think
that instead they're running ads on
health care they're spending just 5.4
million dollars on television ads
specific to impeachment instead the most
prominent democratically funded message
on TV is Mike Bloomberg for president so
the Democrats are not spending I'm
pushing the impeachment effort why
because they know the American people do
not agree with them that Donald Trump
the elected president of the United
States remember 63 million people voted
for him and right now he's favored in
the polls to win reelection in according
to the latest polls out the only
Democrat who's capable of beating him is
Joe Biden and but Biden's fading in the
polls against Trump that he's lost
ground to trump over the past couple of
months and so the American people are
just not buying the argument that if you
don't get rid of Trump the American
people will not be heard now Trump
himself and honestly Trump himself makes
the case for Democrats that he is out of
the box but the American people still
see through them they say yeah no
politics was out of the box you are just
this is just the latest episode in in
Arkham Asylum over here so president
Trump has sent a letter to Nancy Pelosi
it's something that his base enjoys
because the letter is full on Trump I
mean is Trumpy Trump be Trump II it's
something that the middle of the country
kind of shrugs at because they figure
okay well independents like yeah that's
Trump
that's my Trump like we know him we got
it and Democrats are infuriated by
because again two Democrats he's the
murderer he's not the coroner his very
presence is the knife wound in the body
as opposed to everybody else's like ya
know he you know he's just a symptom he
ain't the cancer he's the symptom right
just like most other things in American
politics are symptoms of a broader ill
so here is president Trump's letter to
Nancy Pelosi and it is it is wild okay
it's a wild letter it makes some points
it is colorful and it is just an
indicator that if the American people
want to get rid of this guy guess what a
year from now 11 months from now they
will have every opportunity to do so and
the Democrats don't want to give you the
opportunity to do so they get to make
their case that Trump
not be the new normal they get to make
their case that Trump is everything
wrong with the body politic and you may
not buy that case and that's what
they're afraid of because here's the
thing
Democrats I ask this to Bill Maher once
we're talking about the the Russia Trump
stuff and I said at the time I don't
think there's evidence that that Donald
Trump worked with the Russians to skew
the 2016 election and Maher was like
really you don't is on on real time he's
about two years ago maybe I said I don't
think there's evidence for that and if
evidence does emerge then I will rethink
my position but I don't think the
evidence is there for that and he's like
really you don't think that and at the
same time he was maintaining that Trump
was an idiot I said well you're gonna
have to pick either he's an idiot or
he's a mastermind or he's a criminal
mastermind which is it well Democrats
are sort of stuck in the same position
with regard to this Trump Ukraine stuff
on the one hand he's a criminal
mastermind deviously seeking to skew the
results of the 2020 election by using a
Ukrainian foreign policy to interfere
with American politics on the other hand
he's a done during who stumbles
from place to place now the reality is
Trump is just Trump he's a set of
responses to stimuli Donald Trump is
galvanized frog of politics hey
sometimes it's great he's a contained
nuclear facility every so often the
nuclear the nuclear facility becomes
uncontained and you have run over every
so often you have a near meltdown but
the fact is that the walls of American
constitutional systems are very thick
the cement walls are very thick they
basically contain him and so when we get
glimpses of the of the nuclear power
underneath it's like oh man but do we
feel that he's basically contain I think
the American people basically feel this
is contained now whenever he issues
these letters people on the left leg
land this is why he should be impeached
and guess what because you think you
should be impeached over this letter
this is why we don't trust you really
cuz this letter ain't impeachable now
you've seen Democrats being like this is
the very reason why Donald Trump should
be impeached the letter is basically
just a six page long restatement of his
main thesis which is that the
impeachment is a disgrace something that
he said yesterday in a press conference
here's President Trump explaining that
the vote itself is a disgrace to impeach
the President of the United States for
that is a disgrace and it's a mark on
our country and I'll tell you what
other presidents and in the future
unless they do something about this
other presidents are gonna have to live
with this and every time they do
something that's a little bit unpopular
a little bit strong even if they're a
hundred percent right because I've done
a great job
okay so Trump men sends a letter to this
effect and Nancy Pelosi responds to the
letter is that the letter is sick and
just another reason why he should be
impeached okay well that is a referendum
again on is he the murderer or is he the
corner the letter to her is evidence
that he's the murderer the response from
the American people basically has been
nope you were part of this Nancy you've
been here for years Donald has been here
for like three years you were one of the
murderers of American politics we were
there we remember here's Nancy Pelosi
calling the letter sec essence of it
it's really sick it's really sick guys
it's only it's sick and every Republican
goes yeah you know it's sick you leaping
to an impeachment inquiry without
evidence of an actual crime right that's
what's really sick and just a second
we'll get to the actual text of
president Trump's last his pre
impeachment letter the last letter that
he will write as a non impeached
president in the house I'll get to that
in one second because it is entertaining
it is it is all you have come to expect
from President Trump we'll get to all of
those things in just one second first we
need to talk about the fact that your
computer that your car basically it can
break down and when it breaks down you
don't know how to fix it anymore it
ain't like an old 1965 Chevy where you
can open the engine take a look inside
and fix the thing basically your car is
a computer on wheels and what that means
is that anytime there's a breakdown in
your car it could cost you an absolute
fortune you don't know how to fix it
yourself this is why you need car shield
car shield has affordable protection
plans that can save you thousands for a
covered repair including computers GPS
electronics and more exactly the kind of
stuff that you cannot fix yourself you
get to choose your favorite mechanic or
dealership to do the work car shield
will take care of the rest
car shield coverage gets you back on
track in no time they offer
complimentary 24/7 roadside assistance
and a rental car while yours is being
fixed car shield has helped over 1
million customers already so drive with
confidence knowing that you do have
coverage
America's number-one auto protection
provider I have coverage from car shield
car shield is an excellent company
whether you have five thousand miles or
150,000 miles on your vehicle it is
inevitable that something will break
don't wait until your check engine light
comes on get covered my car shield today
can provide you the peace of mind of
knowing ok your car breaks down in the
middle of the highway you have no idea
what to do with it
you can't take it over to the local auto
body shop and just get it fixed without
spending a bunch money out-of-pocket car
shields got you covered call 800 car
6000 mention code been or visit car
shield calm and use code been to save
10% today that's car shield comm code
been and you can drive with security a
deductible may apply that's car shield
comm code been or 800 cars 6000 and
mentioned code been when you call and
you get 10% off go check them out right
now
and feel that peace of mind of knowing
that you are now protected on the road
okay so here is Donald Trump's
incredible wild letter to to Nancy
Pelosi all of the good all of the bad
wrapped up into a ball from the
President of the United States so here
he is dear madam Speaker I write to
express my strongest and most powerful
protests against the partisan
impeachment crusade being pursued by the
Democrats in the House of
Representatives this impeachment
represents an unprecedented and
unconstitutional abuse of power by
Democrat lawmakers unequaled in nearly
two and a half centuries of American
legislative history okay now you know
that Trump is writing this because he is
capitalizing bizarre words so Democrat
and like lawmakers is capitalized for no
reason not not really sure why to be
fair it is not an unconstitutional abuse
of power the constitute like he couldn't
appeal his impeachment the articles of
impeachment introduced by the House
Judiciary Committee are not recognizable
under any standard of constitutional
theory interpretation or jurisprudence
they include no crimes no misdemeanors
and no offenses whatsoever
if cheapened the importance of the very
ugly word impeachment hey this happens
to be true
hey that this happens they do not
include a crime and this is a point that
I've made right yes it is true that if
Richard Nixon came up from Pietschmann
today probably he would not be impeach
it is also true that at least that
impeachment effort had crimes attached
to it the same thing happened to be true
with Bill Clinton who had perjury and
obstruction of justice attached to it
the Democrats specifically crafted these
charges to avoid including criminal
conduct
they said abuse of power which is not a
crime and obstruction of Congress which
is not a crime the second charge by the
way
instruction of Congress is so
unbelievably weak because again all they
had to do was wait for a judiciary to
force Trump's officials to turn over
documents Trump would have done it and
then there's no obstruction of justice
and so that is just it's an utter
outright lie and he is correct when he
says that these these charges include no
crimes Trump continues by proceeding
with you're invalid impeachment you are
violating your oath of office you are
breaking your allegiance to the
Constitution and you are declaring open
war on American democracy and you know
this this last statement that they're
declaring them open war on American
democracy listen they're using
constitutional means but I think that
the vast majority of the American people
in the end if given the choice between
impeachment and we get to vote on this
guy in 2020 I like let's vote on the guy
the Democrats are treating this as
though this is the final referendum on
Trump which is a bizarre take by the way
they keep saying over and over if Trump
isn't impeached well then he could cheat
and steal the election and so now you
are diligent amaizing every election
from here from from here on in which
Democrats have been want to do in 2016
with Stacey Abrams in Georgia and 2018
Trump says you dare to invoke the
founding fathers in pursuit of this
election at nullification scheme yet
you're spiteful actions display
unfettered contempt for America's
Founding and your egregious conduct
threatens to destroy that which our
founders pledged their very lives to
build I'm not going to say that every
sentence here was written by drama says
even worse than offending the founding
fathers you are offending Americans of
faith by continually saying I pray for
the president when you know this
statement is not true unless it has
meant in a negative sense it is a
terrible thing you are doing but you
will have to live with it
not I not I okay at this point I've
slipped from mild consternation to
enjoyment because if we're gonna have a
circus bring out the elephants man I
want to see the clowns I want to see the
bearded lady I want to see the acrobats
I wanna see the whole thing I'm break
out this popcorn right now because let's
be real I've not been entertained by
this impeachment and I've been rooting
for entertainment because when all hope
is lost at least we can all enjoy the
entertainment correct but the fact is it
has not been enjoyable because you know
the end of the movie so if we can at
least have some pyrotechnics that's good
and Trump is here to provide the
pyrotechnics he says your first claim
abuse of power is a completely
disingenuous meritless and baseless
invention of your imagination you know
that I had a totally innocent
conversation with the president of
Ukraine I then had a second conversation
that has been misquoted mischaracterized
and fraudulently misrepresented
misrepresented
fortunately there was a transcript of
the conversation taken and you know from
the transcript which was made
immediately made available
I was made available upon is becoming a
national issue that the paragraph in
question was perfect mm-hmm I said to
President Solinsky I would like you to
do us a favor though because our country
has been through a lot and Ukraine knows
a lot about it okay here it this is true
Democrats keep saying that Trump said -
szalinski do me a favor it's not true he
said do us a favor he said to America a
favor and this has been my claim since
the beginning is that Trump perceived
his interest to be America's interest
and he was concerned not about 2020 but
about 2016 because Trump is very much
concerned about his vindictive 2016
concerns the Democrats spent two years
investigating 2016 and whether I had
been skewed it does not seem out of the
realm of possibility that the American
people have a right to know what
happened in 2016
up to and including what happened in
Ukraine now was that founded on serious
grounds by Rudy Giuliani we don't know
yet I have serious doubts that it was
but for the president's believe a batch
of false information presented by Rudy
Giuliani and then to ask the Ukrainians
to investigate that false information
believing it to be suspicious or true
about the 2016 election is not a high
crime it is not a misdemeanor it really
isn't even doing anything wrong the only
thing that it's doing wrong is believing
your personal attorney who has very
little credibility on matters Ukraine
related it's believing what is
beneficial for you to believe is why
I've said you know if they Democrats
were smart they would've gone for
century here not impeachment by going
for impeachment they've basically
unified the Republican Party don't get
to more of president Trump's very
pyrotechnic letter in just one moment
first let us talk about the fact that we
are approaching the end of the year you
probably have one of those two duelists
right want to get a bunch of stuff done
before you go on vacation next week I
know that I do well one of the things
that you might want to get done is that
life insurance policy because who the
hell knows what's gonna happen over that
holiday break and the last thing you
want is to leave your family bereft in I
would imagine if something bad happens
to you your family's already in mourning
and suddenly they realize that they
don't have any stream of income suddenly
they realize I gotta pay for that
funeral it ain't gonna go great this is
why you should have life insurance every
responsible adults should have life
insurance but where the heck do you get
life insurance answer policy genius calm
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance
the breeze in minutes you can compare
quotes from the top insurers and find
your best price you could save $1500 or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies once you
apply the policy team policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape and policy genius doesn't just
make life insurance easy they can also
help you find the right home and auto
insurance disability insurance so if you
need life insurance but you're not sure
where to start why not start over at
policy genius com just takes a few
minutes to find that right life
insurance policy apply cross another
thing off at holiday to do less policy
genius when it comes to life insurance
it is indeed nice to get it right okay
we're gonna get back to president
Trump's letter and to Mitch McConnell's
response in the Senate to where all of
this is going everything impeachment
related coming up first great news gang
we have a perfect gift for you to give
this holiday season it is the gift of me
no I'm not gonna come to your house but
it's like I'm living with you well not
quite like that cuz then I mean then it
would be bad but like it's a great gifts
okay it's the daily wired membership
from now until January 1st all insider
plus gift memberships will be 25% off
that means your loved one will get all
the fantastic perks plus the majestic
leftist ears tumblr and you will receive
the savings if you're not already a
subscriber you're really missing out
head on over to daily wire.com and
subscribe again that's 25% off all
insider plus gift memberships this
holiday season give them a gift they
will thank you for all year long go to
daily wear comm slash gift to get your
25% off again that is daily wire.com
slash gift get that 25% off do not wait
stop depriving yourself come join the
fun you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so president from continues with
this letter to Nancy Pelosi that leads
up to the impeachment vote today he says
that in this call with zalenski I
mentioned the Attorney General of the
United States every time I talk with a
foreign leader I put America's interests
first just as I did with President
zalenski you are turning a policy
disagreement between two branches of
government into an impeachable offense
it is no more legitimate than the
executive branch charging members of
Congress with crimes for the lawful
exercise of legislative power now here
Trump is actually making a pretty good
point right the point that he is making
is that Democrats keep complaining that
they think that his Ukraine policy was
flawed well guess what I think is
Ukraine policy was flawed but he was
elected I was not the Democrats in
Congress do not get to control Ukraine
policy at least insofar as President
Trump going through the motions of
military aid presidents from meeting
with foreign leaders he's the commander
in chief he does have extraordinary
power on the foreign policy front just
because you disagree with him and just
because Murray Ivanovich disagrees with
him and just because Gordon Sumlin
disagrees with him and just because
Lieutenant Colonel Alexandrov Inman
disagrees with him that does not make it
a criminal impeachable offense Trump
continues with regard to Biden he says
you know full well that Vice President
Biden used his office and 1 billion
dollars of US aid money to coerce
Ukraine into firing the prosecutor who
is digging into the company paying his
son millions of dollars you know this
because Biden bragged about it on video
Biden openly stated quote I said I'm
telling you you're not getting the
billion dollars I looked at them and
said I'm leaving in six hours if the
prosecutor is not fired you're not
getting the money well son of a he
got fired even Joe Biden admitted just
days ago in an interview with NPR that
it looked bad now you're trying to
impeach me by falsely accusing me of
doing what Joe Biden has admitted he
actually did again that that's probably
an overreach of what Biden is admitting
to their suspicions by Republicans that
Joe Biden was militating against a
prosecutor who was looking into Purisima
which had hired his son hunter for
$50,000 a month to be on its board of
directors which is an extraordinary
amount of money for a useless
incompetent buffoon okay but with that
said Biden wouldn't admit to that but
Trump was suspicious of that is that
completely wrong hard to see why
President Solinsky has repeatedly
declared I did nothing wrong and that
there was no pressure
he further emphasized that it was a good
phone call that I don't feel pressure
and explicitly stressed that nobody
pushed
the Ukrainian foreign minister stated
very clearly I've never seen a direct
link between investigations and security
assistance he also said there was no
pressure Senator Ron Johnson of
Wisconsin a supporter of Ukraine who met
privately with President Solinsky has
said and no time during this meeting was
there any mention by szalinski or any
Ukrainian that they were feeling
pressure to do anything in return for
the military aid many meetings have been
held between representatives of Ukraine
and our country never once did Ukraine
complain about pressure being applied
not once
ambassador summons testified that I told
him no quid pro quo I want nothing I
want nothing I once olenski to do the
right thing do what he ran on okay well
that that is certainly what Trump told
sunland someone then has to find that he
thought there was a quid pro quo but
that's exactly the point is that there
isn't enough for impeachment even if you
are suspicious that Trump is not telling
the truth here the second claim
so-called obstruction of Congress is
preposterous and dangerous House
Democrats says Trump are trying to
impeach the duly elected president of
the United States for certain
constitutionally based privileges that
have been asserted on a bipartisan basis
by administration's of both political
parties throughout our nation's history
as they say I don't think Trump wrote
this whole letter there are parts of
this that are actually quite true and
quite good and well spoken as under that
standard every American president would
have been impeached many times over as
liberal law professor Jonathan Turley
warned when addressing congressional
Democrats quote I can't emphasize this
enough if you impeach your president if
you make a high crime and misdemeanor
out of going to the courts it's an abuse
of power it's your abuse of power you're
doing precisely what you're criticizing
the president for doing and here's where
he got very Trumpy okay so now he's made
his legal points and here we get the
full Trump yeah man he says everyone you
know everyone you included knows what is
really happening your chosen candidate
lost the election in 2016 in an
electoral college landslide 306 to 227
he actually won three or four to 27 but
no problem is in you and your party have
never recovered from this defeat you
have developed a full-fledged case of
what many in the media called Trump
derangement syndrome and sadly you will
never get over it you are unwilling and
unable to accept the verdict issued at
the ballot box during the great election
of 26th it so you've spent three
straight years attempting to overturn
the will of the American people and
nullify their votes you view democracy
as your enemy
speaker Pelosi you admitted just last
week in a public forum that your parties
and
each man effort has been going on for
two and a half years long before you
ever heard about a phone call with
Ukraine 19 minutes after I took the oath
of office the Washington Post published
a story headline they campaigned to him
the campaign to impeach President Trump
has begun less than three months after
my inauguration representative Maxine
Waters stated I'm going to fight every
day until he's impeached House Democrats
introduced the first impeachment
resolution against me within months of
my inauguration for what will be
regarded as one of our country's best
decisions the firing of James Comey see
inspector general reports where the
world now knows is one of the dirtiest
tops our nation has ever seen
by the way Comey was wildly incompetent
should have been fired by the Obama
administration actually a ranting and
raving congresswoman Rasheeda Talib
declared just hours after she was sworn
into office we're gonna go in there and
we're going to impeach the mother effer
representative Al Green said in May I'm
concerned that if we don't impeach this
president he will get reelected again
you're near ally said and did all of
these things long before ever you heard
of President Solinsky or anything
related to Ukraine he here's the thing
about room right and there's what you're
getting from a letter a lot of what he's
saying is absolutely true and that and
that's the referendum on Trump is really
a referendum on broader American
politics and the belief that Democrats
are not going after Trump on solid
grounds that this is just the latest
hook upon which they are hanging their
hat and Trump is putting his finger
there and he is correct about that he's
doing it in colorful fashion but he's
right he says as you know very well this
impeachment drive has nothing to do with
Ukraine or the totally appropriate
conversation I had with its new
president it only has to do with your
attempt to undo the election of 2016 and
steal the election of 2020 congressman
Adam Schiff cheated and lied all the way
up to the present day even going so far
as to fraudulently make up out of thin
air my conversation with President
zalenski of Ukraine and read this
fantasy language to Congress as though
it were said by me and he is
specifically referring to this incident
where Adam Schiff basically did make up
a conversation about how Trump was
shaking down Ukraine instead of just
reading the transcript his shameless
lies and deceptions dating all the way
back to the Russia hoax is one of the
main reasons we are here today you and
your party says Trump are desperate to
distract from America's extraordinary
economy incredible jobs boom record
stock markets or in confidence and
flourishing citizens by the way this is
from sentire 2020 ad campaign and it's
going to work he says your party simply
cannot compete with our record seven
million new jobs the lowest ever on
for african-americans Hispanic Americans
and Asian Americans a rebuilt military a
completely reformed VA with choice and
accountability for our great veterans
more than 170 new federal judges and two
Supreme Court justices historic tax and
regulation cuts the elimination of the
individual mandate the first decline in
prescription drug prices in half a
century the first new branch of the u.s.
military since 1947 the space force
strong protection of the Second
Amendment criminal justice reform a
defeated Isis Caliphate the killing of
the world's number one terrorist leader
al Baghdadi the replacement of the
disastrous NAFTA trade deal with the
wonderful US MCA which is definitely an
exaggeration a breakthrough
I mean NAFTA was not disastrous and also
USMC a mostly mirrors NAFTA a
breakthrough phase one trade deal with
China massive new trade deals with Japan
and South Korea withdrawal from the
terrible around nuclear deal
cancellation of the unfair and costly
Paris climate Accords becoming world's
top energy producer recognition of
Israel's capital opening the American
Embassy in Jerusalem and recognizing
Israeli sovereignty over the Golan
Heights a colossal reduction in illegal
border crossings the ending of
catch-and-release and the building of
the southern border wall and that is
just the beginning there is so much more
you cannot defend your extreme policies
open borders mass migration high crime
crippling taxes socialized health care
destruction of American energy late-term
taxpayer-funded abortion elimination of
the Second Amendment radical far left
theories of law and justice and constant
partisan obstruction of both common
sense and common good this paragraph is
Trump's pre-election campaign in a
nutshell and it is it is very likely to
work because it is simply true that
trumps record on the actual issues has
been pretty good for Americans in the
end that is true and Democrats are
hoping that this election becomes a
referendum on Trump by making this
impeachment effort it starts to become
an election referendum on Democrats and
who's the candidate who can avoid that
who's the candidate on the Democratic
side who can avoid this thing becoming a
referendum on the Democrats own
extremism and their willingness to push
impeachment about political priorities
who can do that
Bernie Miley Bernie right now is leading
in New Hampshire he may be leading in
Iowa he there there not enough polls in
Nevada no bernie is is in solid shape to
at least be competitive for the
Democratic nomination Joe Biden is
durable but he ain't blowing anybody
away in that nomination race so that's a
weak field and Trump knows it he's
putting his finger on it
Crump says there's nothing I would
rather do than stop referring to your
parties that do nothing Democrats
unfortunately I don't know you'll ever
give me a chance to do so after three
years of unfair and unwarranted
investigations forty five million
dollars spent eighteen angry Democrat
prosecutors the entire force of the FBI
headed by leadership now proven to be
totally incompetent and corrupt you have
found nothing few people in high
position could have endured or passed
this test you do not know nor do you
care the great damage had hurt you have
inflicted upon wonderful and loving
members of my family says Trump you
conducted a fake investigation upon the
democratically elected presidents of the
United States and you are doing it yet
again there are not yet many people who
would have taken the punishment
inflicted during this period of time and
yet done so so much for the success of
America and its citizens then now you
can tell that sentence is written by
Trump because it's it's his arm is
barely long enough to Pat himself on the
back there is instead of putting our
country first you've decided to disgrace
our country still further you completely
failed with the Muller report because
there was nothing to find so you decided
to take the next hoax that came along
the phone call with Ukraine even though
it was a perfect call and by the way
when I speak to foreign countries there
are many people with permission
listening to the call on both sides of
the conversation you are the ones
interfering in America's elections you
are the ones subverting America's
democracy
you're the ones obstructing justice
you're the ones bringing pain and
suffering to our republic for your own
personal selfish political and partisan
gain before the impeachment hoax it was
the Russian witch-hunt against all
evidence and regardless of the truth you
and your deputies claimed that my
campaign colluded with the Russians a
grave malicious slanderous lie a
falsehood like no other that hey listen
I get enjoyment from the fact that
President Trump has these sort of key
phrases that he comes back to like no
other it's there is a tsunami like no
hurricane like no other because you can
sort of see Trump just reading this out
loud before a before a a fire a sort of
soft fire glowing in the backgrounds got
that Christmas log out just reading this
out loud you forced our nation through
turmoil and torment over a wholly
fabricated story illegally purchased
from a foreign spy by Hillary Clinton
and the DNC in order to assault our
democracy yet when the monstrous lie was
debunked and this democrat conspiracy
dissolved into dust you did not
apologize you did not recant you did not
ask to be forgiven you showed no remorse
no capacity for self-reflection instead
says Trump you pursued your next
libelous and vicious crusade and
engineered an attempt to frame and
defame an innocent person all of this
was motivated by personal political
calculation your speakership and your
party
are held hostage by your most deranged
and radical representatives of the far
left each one of your members lives in
fear of a socialist primary challenger
this is what is driving impeachment look
at congressman nailers challenger look
at yourself in others do not take our
country down with your party if you
truly cared about freedom and liberty
for our nation says Trump you would be
devoting your vast investigative
resources to exposing the full truth
concerning the FBI's horrifying abuses
of power during and after the 2016
election including the use of spies
against my campaign the submission of
false evidence to a FISA Court the
concealment of exculpatory evidence in
order to frame the innocent the FBI has
a great and honorable people but the
leadership was inept and corrupt I would
think that you would be personally
appalled by these revelations because in
your press conference the day you
announced impeachment you tied the
impeachment effort directly to the
completely discredited Russia hoax
declaring twice that all roads led to
Putin when you know that is an abject
lie I have been far tougher on Russia
than President Obama ever even thought
to be that part's true
he says any member of Congress who votes
support of impeachment against every
shred of truth fact evidence and legal
principle is showing how deeply they
revile the voters and how truly they
detest America's constitutional order
our founders feared the tribal ization
of partisan politics you are bringing
their worst fears to life and here is
where President Trump goes the full
Trump he says worse still I've been
deprived of basic constitutional due
process from the beginning of this
impeachment scam right up to the
president I have been denied the most
fundamental rights afforded by the
Constitution including the right to
present evidence to have my own counsel
President to confront accusers to call
and cross-examine witnesses now again he
does have the ability to to do all of
that in a Senate trial which she
probably won't form oh like the
so-called whistleblower who started this
entire hoax with a false report of the
phone call that there's no relationship
to the actual phone call that was made
and it's not so true the whistleblowers
report on the phone call was basically
accurate he says once I presented the
transcribed call which surprised and
shocked the fraudsters they never
thought that such evidence would be
presented the so-called whistleblower
and the second whistleblower disappeared
because they got caught the report was a
fraud they were no longer gonna be made
available to us in other words once the
phone call was made public your whole
plot blew up but that didn't stop you
from continuing
more due process was afforded to those
accused in the Salem witch trials well
well
not that well I mean they did like
hang twenty women as witches in the
Salem witch trials and the due process
involved some tests that weren't exactly
like superdude processing so ya know you
and others on your committees have long
said impeachment must be bipartisan it
is not he said it was very divisive it
certainly is even far more than you ever
thought possible it will only get worse
there is nothing more this is nothing
more than the illegal partisan coup that
will based on recent sentiment badly
fail at the voting booth says Trump you
are not just after me as president
you're after the entire Republican Party
this is the part where trumpet now he's
back on track right he says because of
this colossal injustice our party is
more United than it has ever been
because again people see this not just
as a referendum on Trump but as a
referendum on the state of American
politics and as a referendum on the
Democrats who were happy to say the same
crap about Trump that they said about
Mitt Romney on a wide variety of other
issues history will judge you harshly as
you proceed with this impeachment sharad
your legacy will be that of turning the
house of representatives from a revered
legislative body into a star chamber of
partisan persecution perhaps most
insulting of all is your false delay of
solemnity now this part this may be the
best part of the letter he says you
apparently have so little respect for
the American people that you expect them
to believe you are approaching this
impeachment sombrely reservedly and
reluctantly no intelligent person
believes what you are saying
fact-check true since the moment I won
the election the Democratic Party has
been possessed by impeachment fever
there is no reticence this is not a
somber affair you're making a mockery of
impeachment you are scarcely concealing
your hatred of me of the Republican
Party and tens of millions of patriotic
Americans the voters are wise they are
seeing straight through this empty
hollow dangerous game you are playing I
have no doubt the American people will
hold you and the Democrats fully
responsible in the upcoming 2020
election they will not soon forget your
perversion of justice and abuse of power
and Trump concludes there's far too much
that needs to be done to improve the
lives of our citizens it is time for you
and the highly partisan Democrats in
Congress to immediately cease this
impeachment fantasy and get back to work
for the American people well I have no
expectation that you will do so I write
this letter to you for the purpose of
history and put my thoughts on a
permanence and Intel Abell record 100
years from now when people look back at
this affair I want them to understand it
and learn from it so it can never happen
to another president again Sincerely
Yours Donald J Trump President of the
United States so there you have
president Trump's final signing off
missive as the House of
votes to impeach him okay well I promise
you we have like two hours of additional
commentary on this later on the radio
shows why should subscribe because as
things develop over the course of the
day we'll be updating we'll get to Mitch
McConnell's plans and and all the rest
but I thought that since this is going
to be what goes down in the history
books the vote and Trump's letter you
oughta have heard from final thoughts
before the actual impeachment happens
okay time for a quick thing that I like
and then a quick thing that I hate so
quick thing that I like I may as well
make an impeachment related thing that I
like I'm amused by the Democrats in the
Senate trying to proclaim that Mitch
McConnell is the real holdup here again
the members of the House of
Representatives have the ability to call
all of these witnesses and the ability
to call Mick Mulvaney they have the
ability to call Mike Pompeo they have
the ability to call my Penn State the
ability to call John Bolton the ability
to do all these things all they had to
do was simply wait for the judiciary to
adjudicate all of this instead they
didn't they rushed ahead because they
knew they didn't have the goods so you
may as well move this thing fast Chuck
Schumer now is trying to put this all in
Mitch McConnell's lab he says McConnell
wants to use the Senate to help Trump
with his cover-up
okay well Democrats did a crap job with
their investigation and now they're
looking from McConnell to clean up their
diarrhea that ain't happening here is
Chuck Schumer trying to pressure
McConnell it appears leader McConnell
after going on Fox News has already made
up his mind about the Senate impeachment
trial it's clear that Senator McConnell
wants to use the Senate to help
participate in a cover-up do you want
someone who proudly says they are not
impartial to be on a jury
judging high crimes and misdemeanors
serious charges against the president to
the United States
okay McConnell's response to all of this
is are you high well in what sense am I
supposed to be impartial I'm a senator
this is a political process this is not
a jury process what the hell are you
talking about you're the ones who have
said all along you don't need to show a
crime because it's political it isn't an
actual criminal process here's Mitch
McConnell going guys I'm not a juror and
this is not an actual like criminal
trial and if it were a criminal trial
you don't have the goods this thing
wouldn't even meet the standard for
prosecution which happens to be true
here's Mitch McConnell going guys this
is just crap
impartial juror this is a political
process there's not anything judicial
about it impeachment is a political
decision the house made a partisan
political decision to impeach I would
anticipate we will have a largely
partisan outcome in the Senate I'm not
impartial about this at all you gotta
love the you know Mitch McConnell he may
be ramming through all sorts of garbage
packages the president Trump approves of
spending packages like 1.4 trillion
dollars in spending which we'll get to
in just a second but when it comes to
this sort of stuff he has a cut to the
bone stone called cocaine Mitch killer
here is Mitch McConnell also adding by
the way I'm not gonna save your garbage
investigation if you think I'm gonna
call a bunch of witnesses that you guys
wouldn't even wait for yeah that ain't
happening
stuff it the Senate is met doc this
judge and jury to hear a trial not to
rerun the entire fact-finding
investigation because angry partisans
rush sloppily through it if the Senate
volunteers ourselves to do House
Democrats homework for them we will only
incentivize an endless stream of dubious
partisan impeachments in the future we
don't create impeachments over here mr.
president we judge them and then Jackie
Speier from California who apparently
has but passing knowledge of the legal
process suggests that Mitch McConnell
should recuse Republican issue you're
right all the Republicans should recuse
themselves in the Democrats those
impartial arbiters of fact in law they
should be the ones who vote by Jackie
spires logic the only people who should
be allowed to vote on the impeachment of
a president are members of the opposing
party can't imagine how that would end
here's Jackie Speier being adult I think
you know we're gonna have to call for a
mistrial before it ever gets over to the
Senate my understanding is that each of
the senators is going to have to take an
oath that they will independently
evaluate the evidence for impeachment
and for conviction it sounds like
there's no interest in doing that
whatsoever and I would think Mitch
McConnell should recuse himself he
should recuse himself recuse himself but
what'd she think this is it's a
political process and if you weren't the
political process again you have not
even charged him with a crime
any time for it
that I hate so the house has now passed
it 1.4 trillion dollar spending bill
because this is what we do these days we
just we argue about impeachment we argue
about colin kaepernick on Nike
commercials we argue about all culture
war issues and then we just continue to
spend to bankrupt our children and
grandchildren here is the house
acknowledging the passage 1.4 trillion
dollar spending bill that will blow out
the budget yet again 75 years ago this
week American forces were under siege
from 200,000 German soldiers over a
thousand Panzers as Hitler mounted a
counter-offensive in the middle of the
freezing cold winter at Christmas
our boys no doubt wanted to get home yet
this Congress surrenders it surrenders
to the swamp mortgaging the future of
the very future those men fought for the
president last spring about a massive
omnibus said I will never sign another
bill like this again I'm not going to do
it again nobody read it it's only hours
old some people don't even know what's
in it
it's 1.3 trillion dollars the second
largest ever mr. president
I look forward to your veto that's
representative chip Roy he is 100%
correct one point four trillion dollars
the Republicans are spending more than
the Democrats ever did there's a the
people have made the case before that
there should be a split government
between Democrats and Republicans
because we actually look at the spending
during those periods it tends to go down
and it's largely due to the Clinton
Gingrich era but it is true that this
thing is boondoggle there's a bunch of
stuff in here and by the way major
issues that are just sort of passed into
law this bill has an actual provision
that raises the smote the federal law
regarding smoking from 18 to 21 s give
to be 21 years old to smoke a cigarette
so you can serve in the military you
can't smoke a cigarette wouldn't you
think that that would you know occasion
maybe some actual national debate now
I'm not a fan of smoking but that seems
like something that you should maybe
have a separate debate on that shouldn't
be in an omnibus package also this
package includes 25 million dollars for
federal research into gun violence which
again is so stupid like they're doing it
under the auspices of the of the I
believe Health and Human Services
Department and at the NIH National
Institute of Health and the CDC the
Center for Disease Control
what does gun violence have to do with
disease or the National Institute for
Health it doesn't if you're gonna do gun
research do it under the auspices of the
DOJ do it under the auspices of the
Department of Homeland Security
doing it under the auspices of health is
a way to suggest that you should be able
to regulate guns in the same way that
you regulate disease which of course is
completely insanity blaze blaze media's
Daniel Horowitz has a long piece today
blasting the budget deal he says there's
no reason why Trump can't demand a clean
continuing resolution for six weeks
while the nation debates and even
discovers the provisions of these bills
he should use the bully pulpit threaten
the veto threaten the veto pen to build
the case for better immigration
enforcement punishing rebellious
sanctuary States and actually put
fulfilling a fraction of his promises on
spending levels that ain't gonna happen
Trump is moving forward full steam to
2020 and if that means blowing out the
budget Republicans will go along with
him all right we'll be back here later
today
with a continuing update on all of the
impeachment related activities today a
historic day the house makes the call to
impeach the President of the United
States historic but non important is it
sort of the the way that this will play
out historically as well as in our
current twenty twenty election debate
but we'll be back here later today to
recap it all for you so make sure that
you subscribe over a daily wire.com soon
to be a great day to subscribe and right
now by the way 25 percent off until
January first so now is a good time to
do it you're listening to the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel white house key
edited by Adam SIA vets audio is mixed
by micro Romina hair and makeup is by JL
alvera production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
[Music]
you